the trisat automation tool additional
features in the devsecops reference
implementation
and new steps to secure ibm cloud
accounts all on this episode of ibm
cloud now
what's up y'all my name is ian and i am
back to bring you the latest and
greatest news and announcements from ibm
cloud
to kick things off this week i wanted to
take a look at a new tool that is going
to make it faster and easier to get
started with ibm cloud satellite
based on many client engagements ibm
garage for cloud has worked across ibm
teams to create the trisat automation
tool
trisat is a white box automation tool
that enables you to set up an ibm cloud
satellite location on a virtual private
cloud infrastructure with just a few
clicks in two or three hours best of all
trisat usually requires just five
configuration parameters to easily set
up resources create a satellite location
provision the red hat openshift
kubernetes service and configure the
satellite link
to learn more about the tool and give it
a try check out the link i put in the
description of this video
next up we've got some new capabilities
and improvements to the devsecops
reference implementation
introduced earlier this year it provides
a complete secure software delivery
lifecycle automated with ibm cloud
continuous delivery and other ibm cloud
services
first among the new features is support
for sonar cube an open source platform
that helps with the continuous
inspection of source code quality by
performing static code analysis
we've also added new image signing
validations that check and validate the
input for the correct format
and finally we've improved the getting
started experience by adding a new ibm
cloud dashboard tile
now you can find all the devsecops
documentation in one place with a new
home page that is consistently refreshed
with content
to learn more about the reference
implementation hit the link below
to finish up this week's episode i want
to give some new info on how we're
securing ibm cloud accounts
our goal is to provide the most secure
public cloud and that's why we will
begin securing user identities and
accounts through credit card
verification when signing up for new
accounts
now no need to worry we won't charge you
for signing up
you can still try ibm cloud for free
users that create a new account will be
asked to add credit card information to
verify your identity and secure your
account
after you register you are equipped with
a pay-as-you-go account and you can
access the full ibm cloud catalog
including all free and light plans
if you already have a light or trial
account there is no change at this time
and if you click on the link below get a
full rundown of all the changes
thanks so much for joining me today for
this episode of ibm cloud now if you're
interested in learning more about the
topics i've covered make sure you
explore the links in the description of
this video
and again please don't forget to
subscribe to our channel to stay up to
date on what's going on in the cloud now
you